diabetes mellitus has been a scourge of
the developed world with an estimated
400 million people worldwide suffering
from this disease and 50% more predicted
within 20 years it's early symptoms
which include increased thirst and large
volumes of urine were recognized as far
back as 1500 BCE in Egypt while the term
diabetes meaning to pass through was
first used in 250 BCE by the Greek
physician Apollonius of Memphis type 1
and type 2 diabetes associated
respectively with youth and obesity were
identified as separate conditions by
Indian physicians somewhere in the fifth
century CE II but despite the disease
being known a diagnosis of diabetes in a
human patient would remain tantamount to
a death sentence until the early 20th
century its causes unknown what changed
this dire situation was the help of
humanity's longtime animal partner
conness lupus familiaris domesticated
from gray wolves thousands of years ago
in 1890 the German scientist von
marrying and minkowski demonstrated that
removing a dog's pancreas caused it to
develop all the signs of diabetes thus
establishing the organs central role in
the disease but the exact mechanism by
which this occurred remained a mystery
until 1920 when a young Canadian surgeon
named Frederick Banting and his student
Charles best advanced the findings of
their German colleagues working under
professor MacLeod at the University of
Toronto they confirmed that the pancreas
was responsible for regulating blood
glucose successfully treating diabetic
dogs by injecting them with an extract
they had prepared from pancreas tissue
by 1922 the researchers working with
biochemist james collip were able to
develop a similar extract from beef
pancreas to first treat a 14-year old
diabetic boy followed by six additional
patients the manufacturing process for
this extract now known as insulin was
eventually turned over to a
pharmaceutical company that makes
different types of injectable insulin to
this day Banting and MacLeod received
the Nobel Prize for medicine in 1923 for
their discovery but Banting chose to
share his portion with Charles best for
his help in the initial studies
involving
but while medical experimentation on
animals remains controversial in this
case at least it was not just a matter
of exploiting dogs for human needs dogs
develop diabetes at the rate of two
cases per 1000 dogs almost the same as
that of humans under 20 most canine
cases are of type 1 diabetes similar to
the type that young children develop
following immune system destruction of
the pancreas and genetic studies have
shown that the dog disease has many
similar hallmarks of the human disease
this has allowed veterinarians to turn
the tables successfully using insulin to
treat diabetes in man's best friend for
over 60 years many dog owners commit to
managing their dogs diabetes with
insulin injected twice daily regimented
feedings and periodic blood measurements
using the same home testing glucose
monitors used by human patients and if
the purified pig insulin commonly used
for dogs fails to work for a particular
dog the vet may even turn to a
formulation of human insulin bringing
the process full-circle
after all that dogs have done for us
throughout the ages including the role
in a medical discovery that has saved
countless human lives using that same
knowledge to help them is the least we
could do
you